[Music]
[Music]
you've got to find this guy you've got
to find him fast
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and hey there everybody
it is episode 66 oh yeah
Cleveland torso murder yes we're going
more true crime again because as you
guys know if you've been listening to
the show my newest book the faceless
villain it's actually the print version
and the e-book might be up by the time
this show goes up I just uploaded the
print version today and it usually takes
you know a few hours for them to get
back to you about the file and whatnot
so if it's not up when the show goes up
it'll be up in the next couple of days
yeah an audiobook usually takes a couple
of weeks yeah the audio book will
probably be two more weeks
the audio book is all recorded I'm just
about halfway through editing the sound
and then I'll have to upload all of it
later and it usually takes at least 10
days for it to go through quality
control on audible so that should be up
shortly but the print in the e-book is
if it's not up already that it will be
up in a day or two so if you want to
check that out please feel free and the
cleveland torso murders that we were
talking about today is actually one of
the cases in there it covers unsolved
murders from 1900 to 1959 and it's
Volume one there's gonna be two more
volumes a second volume be out probably
spring next year yeah when the audio is
ready we'll give you guys a shout out
and now if anybody wants a free sample
copy of the audio just put a comment in
the comment section like you do it and
we'll send you a code yeah
cuz I usually get I usually get twenty
five free codes to you know get people
to write reviews and stuff like that
yeah you didn't listen to it for free
patreon patrons will get priority yeah
and let's see what else Oh our latest
movie review that we put up with Total
Recall if you didn't see that and we'll
be doing more of those in the future we
just saw that new Blade Runner last
night yes it was really really
did not disappoint I was kind of like
well when we were going to see it I was
kind of like well I'm not gonna assume
that it's gonna suck but I said I'll
just assume that it'll be okay yeah and
then sequels usually suck I went to it
thinking I was saying to Genesis this
shit's gonna suck yeah he kept saying
that like like Madison said and I'm a
huge Blade Runner fan yeah and the movie
is true too Blade Runner
it was way way better than I expected
I think it was excellent I think I'm
gonna say I liked it better than yeah
there was stuck to it stuck to it it was
true to the original it stuck to that
concept yeah but it's happening thirty
years later the technology is a little
bit better yeah in the in the world you
know like yeah they've had technological
growth also bunch of stuff has happened
the world has opened up to show you more
of what that world was like you know and
some of the questions were answered you
know like we're kind of answered it was
more like shown why they want offworld
why they're making replicas what's up
with us ai stuff yeah all this stuff
comes into play
it's a bigger they're giving you a
bigger picture yeah the scope is much
larger of the Blade Runner world and I
have to say too that visually it is
gorgeous
not stunning and also I also want to
attract a lot of it was practical
effects it was yeah and I want to give a
shout out to to like the score and the
sound design and stuff like that that
was phenomenal yeah maybe we'll make a
special review video yeah that really
like what I thought that lent a lot to
the yeah yeah we all experienced when
when they showed that city for the first
time we were seeing in an IMAX and that
rawness out yeah man the city was a lot
bigger than it was in the first one yeah
yeah this there had been a lot of say
urban development showing like the tops
of the buildings you're like wow those
tops those buildings yeah and then you
see this in-between where the streets
are going their godless Billy is must be
20 20 stories dead and then there's huge
skyscrapers above those giant massive
things and massive sea walls to hold the
ocean back but it was awesome
yeah it really I mean like I said you
said it we have to
again you can't take it all in it was
yeah I mean you said as soon as it was
over you said that was a [ __ ]
masterpiece it's a masterpiece
it really was that's movie I've seen in
10 years yeah that in Mad Max fury road
yeah there are the two best movies I've
seen recently yeah and I just think it
alas they're two very different kind of
movies they're both movies of greatness
one it's just a great action movie just
action-adventure do the whole thing
that's Mad Max this one's a little more
cerebral that's makes you kind of
uncomfortable you know I saw I felt
other people in the audience getting
kind of uncomfortable with certain
things that were happening in the movie
and it's gone this thing is [ __ ]
awesome yeah yeah I can't I don't want
no spoilers yeah I went into it without
really because I didn't want to see
trailers I didn't want to see anything I
just wanted to approach it couple
because that's how I really like to
watch it unsettling stuff happens it
really doesn't have a lot to do with
gore or anything like that it's just
weird spooky I'm smoking weird a lot of
the imagery is kind of on basically the
idea is what is a real person yeah you
know it's just it was very philosophical
and Brian or which I which I really
liked about it cuz I wasn't really
expecting that things that aren't humans
having a weird relationships with each
other stuff like that
yeah but yeah it's definitely definitely
recommend it and we definitely have to
see it again we might do a special movie
review episode yeah we approach to do
reviewing yeah but we're also probably
the next one like I said our last one
was Total Recall probably the next won't
be Excalibur yeah I have a lot of we
have a lot of blu-rays we wanted to
reviews on all of them I wanted to do t
want to
we have t1 and t2 we have so many of
them yeah that we've just watched
recently we had we have made we have
made reviews formulas yeah so well we'll
get around to all gradually you know
okay so what else also want to remind
everybody about our patreon page and if
you want to go and make a monthly
donation you may do that and get some
neat extra stuff if you'd rather just
give a one-time donation if you'd like
to support the show then you can go to
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com I wrote it down this time
so I wouldn't mess it up you can go
there and there's like a little link in
the sidebar
that says PayPal donation or whatever it
says I
yeah plugin patreon always always a pain
in the ass but the thing is we have to
do it because if not it just stagnates
and every time we plug patreon we get it
pick up we pick up one or two yeah so
you know it's just like building up
building any other channel of building
any other kind of business you have to
start small and you just work at it you
know patron by patron you know if not
then the show won't continue but at the
rate that it's gone feh
this is gonna be with a good Channel and
it'll continue to grow over the years
yeah oh definitely and also speaking of
patreon for our $10 and up patrons you
know we do monthly hangouts the one for
October will probably have to be either
the toy October 21st or October 22nd
because it's boot camp are because of
spooky Empire usually I would do it on
the last weekend of the month convention
yeah we gotta do spooky Empire that's
coming up the 27th 28th and 29th now I
think that I mistakenly on some of our
past shows when I was talking about
spooky Empire I think I mistakenly said
that it was at the Orange County
Convention Center because that's where
it was last year I was out there this
time okay no it's a it's at the Hyatt
Regency Orlando on International Drive
this year well that means we want to
actually get air conditioning then yeah
that would be rad and Wi-Fi so I can
actually use my yeah so I can use my
PayPal thing for my phone and we have a
couple of fans at least one I think that
are gonna be there yeah so make sure you
guys bring your phone so you take
pictures yeah and it's opening earlier
this year I think it's opening at one
o'clock on Friday it doesn't usually
open until later in the afternoon but
our first panel will be helming the sick
and twisted panel which is always the
most fun panel yeah of the weekend and I
throw booze out and I'll be throwing
little bottles of booze out to everybody
don't want some little free booze
that'll be at 9:00 p.m. on Friday night
and we're also going to be on a few of
the other panels over the weekend and we
will pretty much be there all day I mean
we'll be there probably Friday afternoon
yeah like three four o'clock and we'll
be there all day Saturday and until
closing Sunday after all you like pervy
single guys out there there's a lot of
cute girls at these a lot of a really
short skirts just booty hang time
I hope it'll be better this time because
it's like it was okay at the Orange
County Convention Center but I think
it'll probably better at like an actual
I felt like I was trapped in there and
the food wasn't that good this was huge
though huge brand new it's like a huge
empty mall yeah if you ever see like Dan
Bell's [ __ ] dead mall series oh yeah
we definitely recommend those those that
[ __ ] is fascinating yeah and I'm not
like a big mall person I didn't hang out
in malls so much back in the day back
Jenny I'll sit around just listen to
dead malls and yeah we'll just like
watch it yeah with the vaporwave we're
gonna make that one we've decided to
make a vapor wave album and we're gonna
pull that we're gonna put it out on the
and in the data street we're gonna put
it out on our show you guys are like
yeah we've been talking a great deal
like gothic vapor with yeah it's just
like well that music is just like so
evocative it just reminds me of like
walking through walls of these like
hilarious but yeah so we're yeah we're
just sister yeah but in an ironic and
yeah yeah we know that music better than
those kids making that [ __ ] yeah okay so
Oh what else for our Halloween episode
I still need stories they don't have to
be ghost stories but they have to be
true creepy scary stories how about
those two books that you bought at the
mall yesterday Oh awesome
we actually went to a mall yesterday but
it wasn't a dead mall that was there I
was actually very crowded yeah what yeah
you know cuz bread you notice everything
was heavily discounted well that's well
at Barnes & Noble that's always been
like that okay
that's always been like that all right
you know cuz I used to hang out in ferns
and it was you got a complete hardcover
edition of HP Lovecraft and the cover on
it looks fancy yeah it's just you every
every everything that he's written
fiction that he's written yeah like it
doesn't have like his essays on the
super happy but it has all of his
fiction in it yeah the novels and
everything yeah and it's in this big
huge hardback book with silver on the
side of the pages it's so
gorgeous yeah I think what was it like
20 bucks or zoom yeah and the other one
is like a big giant I think it's a
hundred and one of the best like
supernatural stories of all time it's a
magic fiction they had some action
figures there I wanted to buy it
actually they had like a Japanese
version of Darth Vader Darth Vader eyes
yeah like a samurai
yeah or badass yeah they were expensive
those like a hundred bucks each one of
them and then like the Red Bank though
they're the red Imperial Guards yeah
they worth stress like a samurai version
and then like stormtroopers but they're
Samurai it was I've never seen those
before but I saw and I'm like man what a
good idea some kind of an official Star
Wars product but just rebooted as
Japanese samurais yeah pretty neat yeah
they're they're badass I think they were
metal weren't they well if they were
diecast and I don't mind them being
honor dollars maybe some of it was
diecast I don't know I'd play hard bucks
even for a nice plastic figure I got a
hassle in 1970s chickens metal yeah my
Japanese robots my other metal he has a
whole collection of Japanese robots you
grew up a show the Warriors I got the
real things I got the ones from Japan
the Bandai versions yeah fully
articulate very cool he has a friend of
mine makes them yeah from a company
called HL Perot ladymate well yeah and
then oh I got one where it's shout out
my friend Damian Lee Thor wanted me to
shout out his power metal band called
predator who we also did the movie
review on that yeah he has a band called
predator so check out their website at
www.allaboutdoors.com
only killed only killed 12 people but it
could be as many as 20 because there
were a [ __ ] ton of other similar crimes
that might have been him and
disband like several years it was
between like 1921 and 1950 were you know
some murders that could have been him
although his main his main window of
crime was in the night like mid 1930s
okay they just find torsos well and
other parts all right all right it's
good - all right so let's set the stage
Cleveland Ohio in the 1930s obviously
post depression Cleveland was kind of
starting to make a little bit of a
comeback though like some of the
factories started hiring again and
things like that and you know a lot of
people were coming into the city to get
work in the steel factories but there
was still you know because so many
people were coming into the city is if
there's still a great deal of poverty
and homelessness so in Cleveland there's
a part of Cleveland I think it's on the
south east of the city called Kingsbury
run and in Kings with in Kingsbury run
there was kind of like a shanty town or
like you know hobo camps that are called
the flats or the Cleveland flats now it
was within this area that it seems like
this murderer whatever his motives were
took most of his victims it should be
noted that almost all of his victims
were unidentified the killer himself was
also unidentified I don't think he's
still running around out there because
it was the 1930s but you never know he
might be like there would be an old guy
like job with people up out there it
always kind of tripped me out how this
heinous shits going down like in the 20s
and the 30s we always tend to look back
at those times like they were innocent
more simple times but no no people were
bad back then and this is the thing to
like remember we were watching that
thing that was kind of like other crimes
that happened in England like a sign of
Jack the Ripper like in the late 19th
century and also when I was researching
the faceless villain and like I said
that goes from you know 1900 in 1959 and
there were some really [ __ ] horrible
crimes that happened back then I mean
people just like chopping people up with
axes it's like they've been heads please
it's like [ __ ] nasty-ass [ __ ] there's
always a certain amount of
halation that is just evil yeah I wonder
if it had something to do with you know
like mercury poisoning and weird all the
time it might have had something to do
with lead because lead and paint and
lead in the water supply and stuff like
that that does mess up the frontal lobe
of your brain right which that's your
inhibition and all that other yeah a lot
of people are always talking about how
polluted it is instant [ __ ] now I'm
business well not compared to I compare
the way it was yeah it's not not
compared the way it was back in the
early 70s and I was a kid I can remember
just gagging in my eyes yeah it's not
bad
and that's that's not well they've
cleaned it up the Lots has changed a lot
remember that used to be like down the
ditches up trash and garbage every year
now you look at China and China's like
that now but we used to be like that
back in the 70s yeah and I think a lot
yeah I mean it was a lot grosser back in
the day yeah for real they had they had
a commercial of the Indian guy cry yeah
remember that iron eyes Cody but yeah he
played Indians like his whole career but
he wasn't even native he was just TVs
fake okay so picture this it's a 1934
September 5th and there's this guy and
he's walking on the shores of Lake Erie
on Euclid Beach and what does he stumble
across but the lower half of a woman's
torso from waist to knees damn just
laying there on the shore obviously the
police are called and [ __ ] like that and
this woman I think that was the only
part of her that they ever found now the
weirdest thing about this was that the
skin on it was kind of like red and
tough like leathery like some kind of
preservative suspicious already think
about that yeah it's very portable yeah
you know I mean it's like somebody's
making like a portable sex toy yeah well
the thing is though the other pieces of
other bodies were found yeah you know
what I mean they call them the Cleveland
torso murder but that's cuz yeah they
found torsos but they found other [ __ ]
too right you know I mean it just sounds
like some dude is trying to you know
basically make it make a giant pocket
[ __ ] or something
yes I asked him when we get into the
hint into the when we were talking about
the cannibal in the necrofear on the
necrophilia show yeah you still some
people's favorite episode because Tommy
that's correct I start I start to have
these mental problems when people talk
about this [ __ ] yeah yeah because it
starts to become mentally real to me I'm
like well it is really didn't happen
yeah and like I said they never caught
this dude alright I don't like it yeah
so this woman okay so they never found
the head they never found any of the
other pieces and they never identified
who this was and they didn't know how
long that she had been dead because of
the they thought some kind of
preservative was on the skin I guess a
myth I guess it was weird back then you
could kill a person that person could
disappear and nobody would even know
that the person was missing
yeah cuz paperwork was so disorganized
yeah if that was somebody from another
state the family would be in that of the
state looking for that person yeah and I
think that happened a lot and like I
said I think it happened was a lot of
the victims of this murder in particular
because so many people had come into the
city looking for work and they were poor
no they just lived in these shanty towns
and stuff like that so if they got
snatched and got killed that was a that
was it you would never know you know and
most of the time they never found their
heads so you know they didn't know what
they look like or anything like that
so now this woman that was found this
partial woman there is some controversy
over whether this was actually the
cleveland torso murders first victim or
not most researchers think it was but
they're not entirely certain and this
was 1934 so they called her either
victim 1 or victim 0 because they're not
really sure
now the first victim that was canonical
let's say this happened more than a year
later it was September 23rd this was
1935 and this is an area of Kingsbury
run that's known as jackass Hill I don't
know why if maybe somebody from Ohio can
clue me in and this time they found
jackass hell I'm sure there's a I'm sure
there's a good story story but and if
anybody from Ohio knows please tell me
but jackass
fell down that hill or did something or
do you trick somebody to ride ride down
that hill on one of those little land
slaves you know something like that
you need to name [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] name
[ __ ] all-time yeah you do so this time
there were two victims both of them were
men both were decapitated and both were
also emasculated yeah yeah let's call it
that now both of these guys they did
find their heads not attached but they
found them a little way away one of the
victims the one that was older had
leathery skin kind of like the lady in
the lake so somebody had put some kind
of chemical on their preserve yeah this
victim was not identified the other
victim it was a younger guy and this
body had been washed and drained of
blood and had a rope burns on his wrists
now they found his head so they were
able to alive yeah they were able to
identify this guy his name was Edward
Andres II and he was a young gay man and
he had frequented some of the bars in
the area and stuff like that so he was
recognized they found him they thought
that he had only been dead for a few
days the other body which was an older
man they thought he had been dead for
several weeks although they weren't
certain about that the interesting thing
and I guess it's easy to say this in
hindsight but at first they kind of
treated this double murder as a separate
crime like it didn't really seem to
occur to them that maybe it was the same
guy that did the lady of the lake which
absolutely kind of that kind of upsets
me because it's like oh well so it's
just like run-of-the-mill that there's
some dude like running around lopping
off people's heads and chopping those
bodies up and stuff like that that
didn't even occur to them that that
might have been the same guy right I
mean it was only like a little more than
a year between those two things right so
you think people be like oh hey you know
we found that piece of that body or
whatever so then they identify with what
a serial killer was by that time you
know there wasn't an FBI I don't think
1930 was there yeah there were there was
there was I don't think it was called
the FBI I don't think there was a serial
killer
task force yeah this concept that
someone would kill purse people over and
over just for the hell of it birth for
sexual or for sexual reasons is over
periods of years I don't think that
really suck in yeah so the next one that
took place that was probably the same
person this was January of nineteen
thirty six and there was a woman and she
was walking by the Hart manufacturing
building in Cleveland and she found two
baskets and she looks in the baskets for
whatever reason I don't know and inside
the baskets
there was a dismembered woman and each
piece had been very neatly wrapped in
newspaper nice yeah they never found
this woman's head however they did they
were able to take fingerprints off of
the body and they identified the woman
as Florence Palillo who was a bartender
and sometime prostitute they thought she
had been dead about two to four days
four months later two little boys
walking near the East 55th Street bridge
they come across a pair of pants
inside this pair of pants is a severed
head the next day they found the rest of
the corpse and it was dumped in front of
the nickel plate railroad police
precinct this man was also a younger guy
his body had also been washed and
drained of blood probably been dead for
two days they figured he had been
decapitated while he was still alive
some of the bodies were not some of the
bodies were cut up postmortem but this
one they think he was decapitated while
he was still alive now this guy they
never identified him either they ended
up calling him the tattooed man because
he had six distinctive tattoos one of
them had the name Helen and Paul on it
and one said WCG they said they also
found like inside his underwear there
was a laundry mark that had the initials
JD on it so they assumed that that was
the guy's initials now they made a death
mask of him and they put the death mask
on display in 1936 in the summer at the
Great Lakes Exposition to see if anyone
could identify him but nobody did like
no one ever came forward so they still
don't know who this guy is he's just
called the tattooed man another
unidentified
victim then another month goes by July
1936 and then there's a girl walking
through the woods and she finds the
beheaded body of a 40 year old man now
this guy looked like he'd been dead a
long time like he looked kind of
leathery also they did find his head and
a pile of bloody clothing now they think
this guy was killed at that spot in the
woods because they said they were able
to determine like the ground underneath
them was like saturated which soaked
with blood still yeah he's doing two
things he's killing them in secluded
spots and cutting their heads off when
he can when he can't do it that way he
gets him into someplace secluded like
his house yeah kit rapes and kills them
but then he has to cut him up into
little pieces and wrap him up to take
him out of there to transport him out of
there safely without yeah being seen yes
that's why that's why you're finding
some of them in pieces in some pretty
much whole yeah you have to cut them up
in order to carry him out of the house
well yeah cuz otherwise obviously that's
a body packing him up in boxes he's just
saying yeah this is just some money I
bought at the but you can't carry it all
out at once sometimes so sometimes
they'll take half of it out or 1/3 of it
out in one boxes in a day later taking
the other 1/3 out yeah so he's not
attracting attention so that means he
lives he has privacy but he lives in a
populated area
that's kind of what I fit because this
is the type of thing and I just thought
of Silence of the Lambs where they said
that you know he how what's his name the
killer and it like kept the girls in the
basement and starved them and stuff like
that so he needed privacy and it needed
a big area it seems like this guy had to
have that tail yeah because if he was
just like hacking people up in the
street or even like somewhere around
where he lives you think that he would
be seen ya know what it's weird because
no one seems to have ever seen anyone we
got that one guy in the woods
yeah killed him and cut his head off
yeah he's usually able to get them into
his house yeah or a place of work yeah
it's got to be something like that and
you know because I mean that's not
that's kind of a big deal like you know
luring these people and then cutting
them up into pieces and then you have to
wrap them up and you taking him out he's
luring them in there under a roof some
of them across
some of them are probably people that
are looking for work yeah so he's
probably taking some of them to his
house or he's taking them to a place
where he works yeah there he has access
to a place where he works right he he
doesn't own the place he has the keys
yeah
like a warehouse like a warehouse or
something like that and it's actually
kind of disturbing because like I said
what I was researching the book there
were an alarming amount of crimes back
in the 20s and 30s and stuff like that
where people both men and women were
lured to their killer because they were
looking for jobs like they answered ads
in the paper they still do today for
eggs list yeah or somebody you know said
like what I remember one girl like you
know she said somebody from the college
oh they recommended you as a secretarial
job you know what do you know you just
like oh cool I need a job and then they
[ __ ] kill you right that sucks man so
yeah I think that's probably what
happened here
so this guy the guy they found in the
woods they also never identified that
guy even though they did find his head
and then there was another one on
September 10th and this one was actually
found by a homeless man and he was
hopping a train and he tripped over the
upper part of a torso which has got to
be kind of a shitty way to start your
day it's bad enough I'm homeless and
have to like jump trains and now I'm
quite tripping over [ __ ] body parts
and the cops and the cops drank a coffee
and some doughnuts
I hope so they better station house yeah
so yeah so they for me to fall for a
bomb okay so he find they found the
upper part of the torso now they
searched around and they were able to
find the bottom half of the torso and
they found the legs in a sewer nearby
they didn't find the head or the arms of
this one and also not identified now at
this point they finally figured out oh
it's a serial killer so they have two
full-time detectives that they put on
the case or Peter Marlow and Martin
Zaleski and finally the press has dubbed
this killer the mad butcher of Kings
very run yeah and that's kind of an
alternate name like I think later on he
kind of got known more popularly as the
Cleveland torso murderer but at the
time he was known as the mad butcher of
Kingsbury run and they really had no
idea who the [ __ ] this could be I mean
really they had no leads no suspects no
nothing they just knew that there was
this crazy person and they were picking
off poor people from this one area and
cutting them up and leaving them for
reasons unknown and that's kind of all
they knew and they only they had two
full-time detectives on it and they kind
of started trying to figure out who it
was let's take a break right now because
we're at the halfway point and they will
come back and talk about the rest of the
murders I also talked about some of the
other related murders that might have
been the same person and we will be back
in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour to spare check out
our new list channel 13 o'clock in
minutes all the fun creepy topics of the
main podcast but an easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
[Music]
okay and we're back to talking about the
Cleveland torso murderer aka the mad
butcher Kingsbury run now the next
victim did not come along until the
following year February 23rd 1937
interestingly this body was found on
Euclid Beach by Lake Erie which was the
same place that the lady of the lake was
found which is why I tend to think
because like I said some researchers
researchers think that maybe the lady
the lake wasn't one of one of the
Cleveland tourists and murderers victims
but I tend to think probably because you
know how often do you have like them
dumping into the same area yeah but this
was also a woman now this was the upper
half of a woman's torso that was found
floating there and all they could figure
out about this woman was that she was
about in her mid-20s her head had been
cut off after she was dead not before
they didn't ever find the head although
they did find the lower half of her
torso about three months later it washed
ashore a few miles away the next one
happened in June well it didn't happen
in June it was found in June it was a
boy and he was kind of messing around
underneath the Lorraine Carnegie bridge
and he found a skull and near the skull
there was also a burlap sack and the
burlap sack had the rest of the skeleton
in it except for one rib for some reason
I don't know maybe the killer kept it
for a souvenir who knows so there's one
rib missing but the rest of the skeleton
was in there now they figured this this
person must have been dead for at least
a year and I don't know where it was
since then now they looked at the teeth
and they thought that maybe comparing
dental records that this might have been
a woman named Rose Wallace now Rose
Wallace had been missing for 10 months
so they had her son come and look at the
skull and look at the teeth and stuff
like that and he said yeah I think
that's my mom but see the dentist who
had worked on Rose Wallace was dead so
they couldn't get him to come in and
corroborate and stuff like that and some
cops were saying well we think this body
is older than 10 months old so it might
not be her but you know it might have
been her
seem to think it was her but so that
maybe identified maybe not now the next
thing that happened over the summer
there were a bunch of like labor strikes
and riots and stuff like that in the in
the flats and the National Guard was
called in to kind of try to keep order
or whatever and early July one of the
National Guardsmen was standing around
the Koya hugga River and a tugboat went
by and he saw something weird like in
the wake of the tugboat so they went in
there to see what it was and it turned
out that it was a piece of another body
and this was a man in his mid-30s and
he'd only been dead for a couple of days
and so you know the authorities dredged
the river and they found most of the
rest of the body except for the head and
so they never identified this guy either
and after that things seemed to settle
down for a little while they didn't find
another body until the following year it
was April 8 1938 and there was a guy and
he was walking to work and he saw
something on the banks of the Koya
Hobart river that at first he thought
was a dead fish and as he got closer to
it he discovered that it was actually
the lower half of a woman's leg so the
police were searching all around looking
for the rest of the body but it took
about a month before they found most of
the rest of it
they also found a thigh that was from
the same body that was in the river and
then they found two burlap sacks like
under a bridge or something like that
and that had the other thigh the left
foot and the two severed halves of the
torso again arms and head never found
now this woman when they did an autopsy
on her they actually found drugs in her
system so they this was the only victim
that had drugs in their system so they
said we don't know if she was a drug
addict because you know obviously they
never found her arms so they didn't know
she had track marks or what have you or
if the drugs were given to her by the
killer maybe to immobilize her or for
whatever reason so that was kind of an
interesting that was the only one that
was found
like that unlikely it's more likely the
shoes yeah she might been a drug addict
but like I said she was the only seven a
weird feeling you know that this is a
guy that has the ability or at least
appears to have the ability to offer
people jobs yeah that's what I think's
happening is the victimology it's about
50/50 male/female yeah dealing with the
bisexual guy
yeah and he's uh offering people that he
likes jobs getting them into a place
raping and killing them what's going
down with the men that he's men are
probably fighting back that's why you
know some of them are getting their
heads cut off while they're alive you
know that type of [ __ ] yeah some are gay
some were straight yeah he's just gonna
take it he doesn't care if you're yeah
he just seems a very opportunistic I
mean he just seems to be taking anybody
that will come to him oh he's a booty
bandit he's a booty man he's gonna take
it
he's our work he doesn't care he doesn't
care if you're straight he's gonna take
that he's gonna take it from me and that
he's gonna charge gonna kill you if you
resist yeah so he's a bad dude yeah I'm
still what it's almost like guys that do
this kind of [ __ ] it's almost like I
can't even imagine that being a person
like a human being you know what I mean
and I said demon yeah but like I know
that that's bad because obviously you
know yes humans are capable of doing
horrible things gonna be a dude like
John Wayne Gacy type of guy you know I
mean where they get you they they get
you in a spot neg ninny somehow you know
are able to handcuff you or get an
advantage over ya then they start
messing with you and [ __ ] with you and
calling you a [ __ ] and this and that and
beating you up and then hate you sex
start coming in together and then he
rapes you and he kills you yeah and
that's evidently how John Wayne Gacy was
only I think one guy survived it because
he begged his way out of it yeah but
during the whole thing it was more like
a fight than it was it was like a fight
with torture and rape involved in it and
then you know he cut your throat or
strangled you to death stuff like that
so you know that I think the the main
the main emotion behind this kind of
[ __ ] is hate yeah it's not well it's got
a [ __ ] now so much lust is just hatred
yeah and like I said
it's like a bloodlust yeah and I think
it doesn't help to that this this guy
especially I mean this guy was never
caught and they really barely had any
idea of who I could been I mean there
are very very few suspects in proto
could have been so it's like you say you
don't have anything to get a handle on
all right like you know John Wayne Gacy
you know what that guy looks like even
though you're always kind of surprised
when you see somebody that does these
horrible things and they finally catch
them you're like that's it that's that
guy I don't know you just like expected
him to have horns or something monitor
but yeah so okay now the last canonical
Cleveland torso murder victim was found
on August 16th actually that it was two
victims so there were some workers and
they were kind of scrounging through a
dump like looking for scrap and stuff
like that that they could sell and they
found an old quilt that was wrapped
around something and they unwrapped at
the inside the quilt there was a man's
double-breasted jacket and inside this
jacket was yet another woman's torso so
the police came and started going
through the dump and everything like
that yeah they found a box near where
the torso was found and it had a pair of
legs and a pair of arms that had been
wrapped in butcher paper and bound
together with rubber bands they found
the head also and they said now this one
was interesting because they said it
looked like I mean according to the
coroner he thought that this body had
been refrigerated for some time so they
weren't quite sure how long this one had
been they said this had probably maybe
been dead four to six months
but maybe refrigerated so if he gets one
that he likes and he has the opportunity
to keep on user a couple users yeah oh
yeah that's what's his name there's been
several yeah Dahmer did that too do they
try to preserve them and keep them fresh
and that Dennis name Dennis Nelson -
didn't he do that [ __ ] um well yeah a
lot of them try yeah and then you have
the Green River Killer he didn't he'd go
back to meeting character rotten and Bob
he liked a rotten special and then Ted
Bundy did was the same way too he'd go
he'd try to keep him fresh when he could
he'd go back to him yeah the thing is is
that he wasn't always in that he was
always in a position to preserve whole
body so Bundy would save the heads he
put the heads in the refrigerator you
know yeah you know what he was gonna do
it those yep so when they have the
opportunity they do stuff like that
their guys are [ __ ] girls yes it's
not you guys no I mean if I'm talking
yeah and you know this whole concept of
cutting heads off usually involves well
a head smaller fitnah frigerator
yeah but he would put some of their you
know bundy would put heads up on
Mantle's and yell at them and then put
them back in the refrigerator you know
these people are [ __ ] nuts okay so as
if this wasn't bad enough finding a four
to six month old cut up corpse that had
been refrigerated fighting ended up
there looking through the dump four more
pieces and they come across another body
this was a headless man now nearby they
found a big can that had the man's head
in it yeah so this guy they thought he
had been dead for quite a while
like longer than six months for sure
they think he was killed sometime
between November 1937 and January 1938
definitely had a decapitation fetish
yeah yeah because I think heard all of
the victims were decapitated at least
most of the male victims were also their
dicks were cut off yeah to make him
women yeah and his mine some of them
were cut up entire like were cut the
torsos were cut in half of the legs were
cut off the arms were cut off all that
kind of [ __ ] a feat like I said a few
times especially with the men they would
find the body
yeah and the head separate right but for
some reason most of the time he just
like cut him up into pieces now this is
kind of where I think the Cleveland
torso murders and you know Special Agent
Eliot Ness the famous of The
Untouchables I think these two things
kind of became a lot more entwined than
they actually were now Eliot Ness was
kind of sort of tangentially somewhat
associated with the case like he did
interview a couple of the suspects and
stuff now he was particularly pissed off
by these particular two victims because
this dump site was like within view
his office window so he almost kind of
felt like the killer was like taunting
him or something by like leaving them
there like hey Eliot Ness come get me
cuz I mean Eliot Ness was quite famous
at the time
so because Eliot Ness was so pissed off
about this and was pissed off that the
police had not been able to catch this
psycho a couple of days after these two
bodies were found he's like you know
what we're gonna go to the Cleveland
flats and we're just gonna [ __ ] torch
it yeah so I mean you know which I don't
know if you'd be able to do that
nowadays but like back then they gave no
[ __ ] I guess so Ness goes down to the
hobo camps of the shantytown and he's
got like fire trucks police vans squad
cars everything that they scooped up 60
dudes just cause like you know yeah
you're a suspect you're a suspect you're
a suspect get in the van and then they
got everybody out and they just [ __ ]
torch the whole thing and they burned
the whole thing in the ground
it's always funny back in those days
they would suspect people that really
had no means to commit these kind of
crimes yeah this was a middle class guy
probably yeah well I feel like back in
the day like they didn't really have you
know it's not great now but at least we
have like DNA and we have like you know
CCTV cameras and [ __ ] like that back
then then you have any of that [ __ ] so
it's like I kind of feel like and in a
lot of cases that I investigated for the
book I was sitting there's a third she's
really this sense of like desperation
where they're gonna smell like anybody
it doesn't matter just were you there
we're okay you you're under by go after
these transient guys that don't have a
pot to piss in and no place really to do
this right you know they haven't even
been in the area long enough and they
start kind of scrutinizing those guys
yeah this was some kind of local
business owner it probably was like I
said because it had to be somebody with
like you said the means they had to have
some kind of privacy yeah something like
that and like you said it had to be
somebody with the means to like lure
people yeah some it was some of the
occasion jobs yeah that but that does
really seem like the most likely
scenario so you know so Eliot Ness he's
burned the whole area down now obviously
even back then people were like now that
was a little much okay you didn't need
to do all that it should be noted that
none of the people they picked up during
this raid they were all later released
because they said no
none of them we're considered a viable
suspect however it does seem as though
burnin down the Cleveland flats did they
think stop the crimes because they don't
think they were there were no more
canonical murders after that so they
don't know if the guy lived there or if
he just said [ __ ] it I'm moving
somewhere else where is easier pickings
or whatever that may have been his prey
pools well it was they know that for
sure so once they're gone he doesn't
have anybody to yeah jobs to right
that's what I think it was now it should
be small business owner somebody that
owns it owned a little shop or owned a
little warehouse or maybe like a small
mechanic or something like that
something dumps something you'd never
really yeah and it should be noted too
that there were some that I'm gonna talk
about in a minute but there were some
crimes - that took place later like in a
different area that might have been the
same guy so there is some evidence to
suggest that after that big fire he just
thought oh well that's that's a wrap I'm
gonna go somewhere else and start doing
this [ __ ] yeah now yes as well as many
other researchers into the case one of
their main suspects was this guy named
dr. Francis Sweeney he had actually been
a medic in World War one and he was
arrested and Eliot Ness interviewed him
now Sweeney failed two polygraph tests
although I mean polygraph tests are not
all that accurate now and they were even
less accurate back in the 30s but they
did find it suspicious that he had
failed two of them and Eliot Ness did
think that Francis Sweeney was probably
the killer however he never really got a
chance to prosecute him because Sweeney
was related to Eliot Ness his political
rival as well as the sheriff of
Cleveland so he never got he never got
tried for any of that would sweet Eve
had motive did he have a did he have
some kind of a psychological well now
now see what happened later on was that
dr. Sweeney actually voluntarily
committed himself to a mental asylum
later on and he was actually in a mental
asylum until he died in the 60s
that doesn't make you see Rico I know
but that's that's what I mean but I'm
saying Eliot Ness thought that was him
but who knows and the weird thing too is
that after they
put him after he put himself in the
mental asylum he spent the next several
years like writing taunting postcards to
Eliot Ness and his family about the
murders I don't know what it was just
like saying he sucked I don't know what
they said exactly but I was like that
seems like a weird way to spend his time
but whatever now the only other guy that
was actually picked up for this in 1939
they arrested a 52 year old man named
Frank Dolezal and they arrested him in
conjunction with the murder of Florence
Palillo who was considered the third or
the fourth Cleveland torso murder victim
that's considering whether you take lady
in the lake into the tally right now
Dolezal initially did say that he had
killed Florence although he said it was
self-defense like she started a fight
with me and she was hurting me and stuff
and then so I killed her and he made a
bunch of confessions but then later he
recanted them because he said that the
cops had beaten the confession out of
him it could be positive yeah now six
weeks after he was arrested they found
him hanging in his cell an apparent
quote-unquote suicide however some
sources say that he had a bunch of
broken ribs that were not there when he
was arrested right-sized so he might
have been right that they beat that [ __ ]
out of them right so they don't know I
mean I think even nowadays I think most
research researchers are saying no that
wasn't the Cleveland or I bet you didn't
even come close to catching this guy I
don't think they did because check this
[ __ ] out
like I said his official tally is 1213
if the lady in the lake is counted
however there were a bunch of similar
crimes that took place spanning 1921 to
1950 that could have also been him like
in 1936 July of 1936 they found a
headless man in a boxcar in New Castle
Pennsylvania
they also found three headless bodies in
other boxcars in a place called McKees
Rocks Pennsylvania and that was in 1940
and these were all very similar the way
they found the bodies very similar
situation very similar wounds they also
found a bunch of dismembered
bodies in the swamps near New Castle
Pennsylvania between 1921 and 1934 and
again between 1939 and 1942 you know
that now I'm starting to change my
theory maybe he could have been one of
those vagrants in that camp maybe and
when they well camp down he traveled and
moved with the walls yeah across the
u.s. ends up being a railroad hobo yeah
yeah their heads and then he stopped
being a railroad hobo maybe joined some
kind of camp somewhere in swamps you
know may have been something like that
yeah so but the thing is this matter you
have to have privacy to do what he's
doing
yeah that's what I unless you really
know the lay of the land right and he's
showing these bodies off he's putting
them back where they can be found he's
advertising he's not hiding the bodies
not really I mean you know most of them
I mean that make you hide about some of
them yeah some of them weren't found for
a long time but it's like if you're just
throwing him in the water obviously
that's a yes that's gonna wash up
somewhere eventually so in 1940 there
was an article in this in the Newcastle
news in Pennsylvania and they called
this killer the murder swamp killer but
they think this might be the same dude
now in 1950 there was also a man named
Robert Robertson this guy was I was
identified and they found him
decapitated now that was back in
Cleveland so this also might have been
the same guy so this guy might have been
doing this is like he went to Cleveland
he went to Pennsylvania then he went
back to Cleveland and was like chopping
people's heads off all over the place
you know had a child yeah so what that
now that made one of the main
investigators on the Cleveland torso
murder case Peter Morello and this guy
there's actually a picture of him ital
put it in the YouTube video because I
found it but there's a picture of him
like dressed up like a like a classic
like Halloween costume hobo with like
the Hat and the way the bindle and
everything yeah and he would go
undercover as a hobo and he thought that
probably all these other murders that
took place in Pennsylvania he thought
this was the same guy because he pointed
out he's like there was a railroad the
Baltimore and Ohio Railroad line that
went between Cleveland and Philadelphia
yes he's run trains twice a day so he
thinks that you know this guy was just
riding back and forth and like [ __ ]
killing people or
whatever yeah now there is also the same
guy Peter Merrill or the investigator he
also thought that the same guy who did
the Cleveland torso murder murders also
killed the black dahlia because she was
likewise cut in half I mean I think that
yeah it was similar but to me that seems
like the only thing that was similar
about that Galia was knowledge she was
not a transient she was never nowhere
near close to a bomb no and this was
bomb violence that took place way out in
Hollywood man yeah it was like where
California it's like that really doesn't
seem I mean yes where this guy is
that's not his scene but she wasn't
beheaded yeah she wasn't I mean her
[ __ ] pubic hair was picked out one by
one by hand that is like that is a
[ __ ] yeah yeah I mean well he was
that was not his scene right so I don't
think that that's probably what it is
every was dude doing this was connected
to hobo camps and connected to railroads
yeah that's kind of my feeling about it
whether he was like a quote-unquote bomb
himself or I kind of doubt it maybe he
was a little above bomb stat yeah if he
actually maybe you know maybe he was
like so working-class and not with the
bombs
yes sir like you said maybe he was like
a working-class guy who owned a small
shop or something like that and where
had some place where he could do that
kinda where he could make contact with
bombs and offer them things and kill
yeah although it should it should be
noted that there's one guy his name's
Jack Anderson Wilson also known as
Arnold Smith and he was not only a
suspect in the black dahlia murder he
was also a suspect in the murder of
Georgia Bower Dorf from 1944 that's also
in my book and he was also a suspect in
the Cleveland torture murder case so was
it this guy hmm I don't know like I said
black dahlia I kind of tend more toward
the dr. hypothesis just because of
because of her mutilations and like I
said she wasn't beheaded although she
did have
her mouth was cut the corners of her
mouth were cut although what they call a
Glasgow smile where they cut it all the
way to their ears yeah she had that done
and stuff but I don't I don't think it
was the same person as the clitoris you
murdered that it's just the locations
are too far distant it didn't seem like
the same motive to me but you know not
the same kind of offender yes not the
same social circle either right so I
mean like I said at this point since it
should happen in the 1930s possibly the
last crime in the series may be 1950
that that guy that was beheaded and
Robert Robertson in 1950 that might have
been the same guy but at this point I
mean that guy how long ago was that he's
got to be dead by now right yeah so I
guess we're never really gonna figure
out like this is all unsolved if he'll
never be solved yeah I don't think this
is ever one himself because it was so
long ago yeah you know like they didn't
even identify most the victims and if
you look in the Cleveland Police Museum
there's and there's pictures of it on
the internet they've made like death
masks of the decapitated heads and stuff
they found and they put them though with
nobody ever identified it think of it
this way the guy who did this the
offender died in obscurity yeah or he
died when he died he had no evidence on
him yeah so he covered his own tracks he
was you know either way yeah he was a
business owner and he was doing this
when he died there was no there were no
there was no physical evidence to
connect him to these crimes so that yes
he was very careful or he was just
another bum dying in obscurity he had no
physical evidence on him yeah to connect
him to these crimes yeah so know you'll
never yeah like I said it must have been
something like usually when it's a guy
who's a sophisticated killer like that
you know where he's using a business and
he's keeping trophies when he dies he's
discovered yeah because they find out
[ __ ] yeah they never found that no I
still wonder where like the heads and
arms and [ __ ] that they never found
where the [ __ ] did that [ __ ] go what are
you hamburger or animals guy Adam Scott
yeah I guess I'll never find any of that
[ __ ] no that's pretty creepy yeah this
is why I'm fascinated with this guy shot
that even though they said this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is disgusting and like I said
I was looking for pictures for for the
YouTube version of the show you got all
kinds thing and I'm just like oh man
well they just like [ __ ] headless
bodies and chunks of bodies and [ __ ]
like that I mean at least they're all
black and white so it's not super
disgusting yeah I'll put him in there
anyway so you know all right so we're
getting to the end of the show hope you
enjoyed this true crime extravaganza and
remember that my new book the faceless
villain which includes this crime the
black dahlia georgette bauer Dorf many
many many other unsolved murders from
1900 to 1910 Sipan yeah and yeah it's
it's a fun you know compilation and all
your favorite unsolved murders are in
there and some you may not even know
about because I tried to dig deep and
find some that worked so well known in
the end there's two more books to come
yeah yeah the next volume I think this
is gonna be it I think there's gonna be
a popular I'm gonna try and get volume
two out by spring of 2018 but we'll see
how that goes so yeah that should be out
the print and the e-book should be out
if not by the time the show is up then
at least this week and the audiobook
will probably be out in about two weeks
but I'll give everybody heads up when
that goes and please help us grow the
channel like share and subscribe yes on
patreon yes become a patron of our show
and get all kinds of fun stuff Google
Hangouts and free books and stickers all
kinds of neat stuff like that also like
I said if you don't want to give a
monthly donation then you can go to our
blog at 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com
and there's a little link there for a
PayPal donation but one time support
one-time donation if you want to support
us that way and also remember to come
see us at spooky Empire at the end of
the month 27th 28th and 29th at the
Hyatt Regency Orlando not the Orange
County Convention Center as I said
before Hyatt Regency Orlando and
International Drive will be there all
three days and will be helming the sick
and twisted panel on Friday night at 9
p.m. and will also be on a bunch of
other fun horror panels over the weekend
and also oh and remember if you have any
scary true stories paranormal or
otherwise please send them to grave cake
at gmail.com and perhaps they will be
featured on our fun Halloween
special I really need some more stories
yeah if you do if you don't want to
write it down maybe you can contact us
on Facebook and maybe we can do it do a
video or something well do it a video
interview maybe yes that works too I
mean anything you know just as long as I
have like this an audio format something
like that because like I don't like it
right yeah I don't know yeah so if you
don't want to write it down or if you
have it written down elsewhere and you
want to give me a link to it then that
would be cool too you know so hopefully
we can have some fun stories to feature
on our highways on our Halloween special
and that will do it for episode 60 of
the 13 o'clock podcast we will see you
guys next Tuesday and the children count
to 12 save them from
the true
[Music]
you
[Music]
you